so our next speaker is going to be done
at home from University of Oxford he
will speak about the Dakota me another
tea company for queries this negation in
progress Val I would like to thank the
organizers for inviting me this talk
will essentially build on top of of the
previous tutorial essentially will try
to look a bit at the case of negation
right in the previous tutorial what we
have seen was mostly we looked at
conjunctive queries looked at union of
conjunctive queries there was a one
approach to deal with negation but
negation was only applied to relational
symbols and other question is what
happens if we have negation somewhere
else in the in the in the query it is
just a preliminary work in the sense
that the picture is not clear is not
completely clear but at least for some a
fragment of first-order logic we have we
have a good picture of what's going on
there and i will just shortly overview
some some notions of provides databases
hopefully they are actually still clear
in your head from the previous tutorial
i will only use tuple so-called tuple
independent products databases which are
exactly the type of databases dance
which you talked before essentially what
this means is that you have a normal
database but with every single tuple you
associate a distinct random variable and
this is a boolean random variable right
and this random variable gives the
probability for that tuple to be in the
database so essentially by setting the
such variables two trillion false you
can think of tuples being in or out of a
possible instance of the of the
probabilistic database right in if you
think that we have let's say n possible
tuples out there then by flipping in and
out every single one of them we can get
you to the end possibilities right and
so then also argued before it is not
visible in databases to simply iterate
over all this
possibilities right so what we'd like to
do if at all possible to when when given
the query to try to evaluate this query
on top of this probabilistic database in
a time which is polynomial only in the
representation in this representation as
you know database with the probabilities
right and not in its expansion in the in
the in the set of possible words because
this is explanation okay so that's
essentially what I what I what I want to
say here and how you can compute the
probability over world well you look at
the variables in the in the database you
have right and you take a sign monette's
say out of the total assignment over the
variables that it finds the world and
then we take the product of the
probabilities of these assignments you
fix one for instance is true this means
the tuple t1 is in the database a fix to
for instance is forced this means that
tuple t2 is not in the database and then
if that would be the only to do and this
would if this would be the only tuples
we have in the in the privacy database
then the probability of that particular
instance would be the priority of x1
being true multiply the probability of
these two being false right so that's
the setting is a very simple model as
the language I will start with the
language which arguably perhaps is not
very pleasing 40404 logicians but I will
actually discuss also the case of
languages closer to to to to your heart
perhaps i will start with relation
algebra and i'll try to motivate this
towards the end why why i started with
this this is a popular database coraline
language since called time since in 1970
we have as algebra carrier the set of
all final relations and then we have
operations like projections cartesian
product difference and so on and so
forth when I when I when I was saying
that I'm looking at negation in the
context of privacy databases I really
meant here said difference right I you
take the difference between two
relations for in-store between two sub
queries and this is nevertheless as
expressive as domain relational calculus
or first order predicate calculus so
is also known for four decades now i
will look at the particular fragment of
this language which relates very much to
one of the the result so dance what you
presented before namely i look at this
language of no repeating conjunctive
queries imagine you have in this case
relational algebra right so that is you
are allowed to have in this particular
case projections you can do cartesian
products you can do a difference you can
do joint we can do selections but you
cannot do unions right for the moment i
will come back to the union case a bit
later and we do not allow repeating
relation symbols this turns out to be a
headache in probabilistic databases
right repeating relation symbols because
you get non non trivial correlations in
different parts of the query because the
same relation symbol carrying the same
variables random variables of course
over and over again right so this is the
other kind of setting we have here and i
will give you a few examples for
instance there is a very trivial example
that takes a product of two relations
R&D and also product of U and V and then
takes the difference between them and
then projects away all all very
variables right so you know in a perhaps
more familiar syntax we say air rnt and
not u and V and at the end we have a way
we quantify over a and B let me say
exists exists be such that this holds
right and we are interested in in the
probability for instance that actually
such a queries is true of second query
is the one used by by by donning his
tutorial to show hardness results this
is the query that joints are in s and T
such that RNs would join on a query
variable let's say a and SNT would join
on another query variable called be in
this case right and essentially this
this is a symbol for the join it says i
have r and s NP by reusing the same
variable or different places we really
you know essentially and called joints
right that is RNs
on a and SNP join on be okay so that's
the the the basic thing and the query
parish of evolution problem in our
setting is this we are given a query and
for any tuple independent database we
would like to computer probably that Q
is true in a random world off of this
database and we are interested in the in
the data complexity of this problem as
Dan mentioned before we're where we fix
the query and we take the database deeds
input and we will see that in fact it
does have a important role in our in our
discussion here that we consider the
query fixed but so what is the the main
idea of this whether the main result of
this talk is essentially a similarly to
what down and showed before four
different languages to show that in fact
if you are given our language our
language that you know is this
relational algebra with no repeating
symbols and with the with difference
this time with negation then some
queries are easy right where are some
queries are hard for some queries you
can just walk but for others you have to
climb to get them right and this is
actually depicted very nicely here
buying this sculpture by yield Bluebell
where as you can see well it's called in
fact the dichotomy where some parts go
this way whereas others go the other way
right and and and this is a surprising
result which when done proposed the
first time in 2004 this result for the
way what he calls now the small
dichotomy result for this not repeating
conjunctive query language it was it was
very interesting because essentially it
says that some queries are are very very
simple you can compute them very in his
days in polynomial time but in fact the
queries the no repeating contracted
queries can in fact be be completed in
England time assuming you know
convenient sorting of the database
beforehand and all others are Sharpie
hot so there is a wide gap between the
very hard queries and the very easy
queries and there is nothing in between
turns out that the twist for the
fragment I isolated out of relational
algebra the same idea holds right that
some are very easy and some are very
very hard and now the perhaps the most
surprising result is that this very
simple property he mentioned before they
need the hierarchical property also
holds here that is this is the property
that separates out the good from the bad
if you write the ugly from the from the
from the handsome but but but this is in
a sense of surprising for several
reasons one reason is that if i start
with queries in my language and I
actually rewrite them i can transfer
them into a relational calculus formulas
for instance right and they may have
disjunction and they may have repeating
symbols right so it goes beyond so the
power of this characterization of the
hierarchical property characterization
goes beyond just that the very simple no
repeating conjunctive queries okay so
another yeah so I think I think did so
this would be that the domain I would
say a surprising result checking the
hierarchical property given a query can
be done very efficiently you can do it
in ic0 essentially right and why is this
irrelevant well it is relevant because
you know as a database systems person if
I get the query you know my my sister my
engine gets the query I can decide very
quickly whether I should employ this
exact computation technique for the
tractable queries what i should do
approximation for instance right now
having a characterization that is
actually not that effective that would
take a lot of time you know to look into
right it's perhaps prohibitive and you
might go you know uniformly for all
queries with with approximation and we
try to understand how far we can go with
this language so that we can still get
this dis hierarchical property satisfied
right so i will present you the
definition again perhaps slightly
different but in fact it's equivalent to
the one then then gave before namely
that if you look at boolean queries
let's say yeah in our in our language
then
queries hierarchical if if we look at
every pair of distinct weary variables
let's say a and B they have different
colors right red and blue there is no
triple of relations rst such that our
has a but not be right as query
variables right are being a relation
symbol then s has both a and B and he
has be but not a right that is we don't
have the situation in which we have s
sitting between rnt yeah this is
actually depicted very interestingly by
by a painting yeah showing a dance this
is a Romanian dance called hora when I
was a child I was somehow you know
forced to go to weddings yeah to dance
the girls and it was always hard for me
because you know sitting in the middle
and then Siegel is synchronizing with
the others was very very hard and now
decades later I understand why it is
intractable right sorry not like holy
hell oh I like but somehow it's very
hard to you know balance them out to
synchronize with the others right and
and and now the reason is a blogger goes
beyond just I mean if you think of hands
just being joints then that would be the
case of non-repeating conjunctive
queries so if you think of these hands
also being some different operations
right negation then that would hold as
well right what I can do however is this
right this I can do I can dance with one
partner right or you know I actually
took the liberty to to you know destroy
a bit the original painting of a former
former classmate of mine I can take the
same picture and can put it a different
places and inside the itself right this
means that I can actually do a join here
as long as the query variables are
actually covered by another relation
which does a join me something else and
so on and so forth so these things I can
do so these are in fact tractable
queries they are easy they are
hierarchical you see we have these pairs
dancing with in another you know bigger
entity that dances with something and so
on and so forth so that is hierarchical
this this weekend deal with as examples
of hierarchical queries in our syntax
look at
first one the first one joins rns on a
and then takes a difference with T but
now the interesting thing is that a
occurs in all the relational symbols
right okay so we don't have the
situation where r is only 80 is only B&S
has both right all others are in fact
variations on the same theme where we
can actually have a and B not according
in in a relational symbol together right
but they they may be intertwined in some
weird ways the waist is this language
allows what is also interesting is that
negation and projection which
essentially means extension
quantification negation can appear
intertwined in this square in some
arbitrary way so it is not necessary
that negation only appears on relational
symbols but may appear on entire sub
queries right what about not
hierarchical queries well so this is the
the standard one we've seen before but
there may be some others for instance I
take a joint between RNs on a and then I
throw away the be from here right and
then well sorry I throw away the a right
and then I take the difference with T
right so here you see I can have a
difference and this difference acts in a
way as that's our joint with respect to
our to these two disheartens results
right so we have our st but now they are
connected differently not only by joints
but also by negation we can also take
the other form right p minus d the rest
and we can also mix them in any way we
like yes where is the joining end of
them here yeah you have this night
picture of the bridge and the bridge
would be this your definition should be
taken as a metaphor notice the
mathematical definition
the definition you mean with the dance
no definition before the right ABC mu
definition there yeah so this one yeah
well I simplified the idea is this that
that if you do joints essentially the
exact definition is this you look at
equivalence classes of query variables
and the an equivalence class is defined
for variable is define us you know all
other variables which are transitively
equal to this by looking at the quality
joints but also those that are forced by
difference operators right so the
difference operator if you take the
sub-query minus another subtle query it
means you have to provide the mapping
between the variables the second you
should not be taken literally because
it's not really a triple of relation
symbols now you only have two relations
symbols no no you mean here it's rst its
rst oh I so you meant that so we have
our st right so it's always too yes is
it as simple as saying that your notion
of hierarchical means take the quick he
raised all the symbols and replaced by
conjunction then that's a concern if we
each character in the sense of that yes
yes yes yes with the with your own
exception that in case obviously I mean
some tiny tank technicalities if you
have renaming operators or whatever you
have you have to look at query variables
which are actually made equal x by the
query right which may mean by by means
of transitivity of the equality or may
mean by by by mappings for further for
the difference operator but that's but
that's exactly the thing which is
falling back to the same
characterization essentially right so
let let us look at this hard queries
which are I guess the interesting ones
so i will give you a few i will try a
few of you know sketches of frida proofs
right to show hardness i will start with
a very simple one in go go go go to a
bit more complex ones to a bit
appreciate the fact that not everything
can be treated with the same i mean
handle with the same stone you throw the
stone and that's yet all of them will
fall down the same uniform way
the idea is to do a reduction from the
Sharpie heart model counting problem for
a positive by a bipartite dnf right
ideas you are given a non-hierarchical
query in our formalism then any positive
x party DNA formula sigh so imagine a
DNA formula right but every clause has
two literals monitor comes from a set
and the other little from another set
right so so if this census is bipartite
because if you represent it as you know
let's say a graph right is though is a
is a such a graph right and and then
excess between themselves do not have
edges but they have with the wise from
the other side right so you can have
such as such a graph representation of
it and the idea is that you compute the
the number of models of sigh then you
can use linearly many calls to an Oracle
for for that that computes for you the
probability of the query right and the
way you do it you take the formula and
you somehow generate a database such
that the query applied on that database
you know gets the grounding of it with
respect to that database or is in fact
your original formula or a formula which
actually helps you compute the models of
the of the original formula right so
that that's that that's the kind of
general approach of solving this disease
problems at least in probabilistic
databases so the simple case is this is
the case of RS T right where we have
only joints and L so this is the query
right rst you join our with s and T and
then it's a boolean query so you imagine
that this is just an exists a exists be
you quantify over mb and now we have DD
simple formula for the for the sake of
the presentation with this closest and
this is a positive by particle to DNF
also posted by party formula so what do
you do you do this you somehow from this
formula generate databases such that you
know applying the query on the database
gives you back the grounding would be
the original formula so what do we do
for our we just create a tuple for every
single variable in our statics right in
this case I
actually abuse a bit of notation so I
say I have the constant expand and it's
variable is also e61 right so this means
that is tuple is in with the valix one
you know depending on the on the on the
on the value of this variable a random
variable and X 2 is mythix 240 I do the
same but for the other set for the set Y
and for the s and this is the essential
important point we have a to put in s
for every single clause in our original
formula why so so that when we join our
SNT as guides which tuples in our are
paired with each to [ __ ] ness and
that's the idea it's very simple so this
tea would be simply true this means that
this table is in fact deterministic
whereas the others are not deterministic
so this one has four possibilities right
because we have to topple so each one
can be in and out and eat the same so if
we actually do using relational engines
we do the processing where we also
propagate this additional information we
carry over the the lineage or the
grounding at the end we get actually our
original formula we started with and and
then obviously right if we can compute
the probability of this using our Oracle
and we assume that all the value random
variables have probability 1 over 2 we
can then go back so for me laps I and
compute its its number of models right
very easily these two to the N times the
probability right so it turns out that
if you only look at positive queries I
mean no repeating conjunctive queries
this is the only minimal pattern you
have to deal with and everything else
falls back to this pattern right by for
instance having additional joints that
you can do with relations that can be
just trivially filled with with with
information which would not affect the
final result right well in case of
negation things get a bit different so
this is a surprise in case I consider
this query which joins TNS right and
then takes r minus this result right
where i throw away the be right so i
only project on a it's like I have the
exist be in here right so I take our
minus this now it turns out that for
this particular query the rst pattern
that can give me hardness is enough to
have just a single relation
probabilistic and the other two
relations can be a deterministic this is
because with this negation and
existential quantifier we simulate some
some universal quantification in there
so essentially what we do here to to
essentially recover the original upside
our input formula was the result of our
query we do the following construct the
database so we fill in our TNS in the
following way for our we just mention a
row for every single close we have in
there in our original formula so we have
the first clause in the second clause in
t we essentially have a row have a tuple
for every single variable we have in our
formula right we have X 1 we have y1 we
have y2 and as it's a let's say lineage
or a notation we use the negation of
that of that formula and in s we
essentially list which closes have which
variables so we say that one close one
has variable 1x1 close one has variable
Y 12 x 1 + 2 y 2 and this is
deterministic this is deterministic only
this one is probabilistic and what
happens is that once you join p and s
you get the same information as in s but
we're now the information every row will
become annotated with with the with the
formulas of a random variables coming
from t essentially saying that close one
has x 1 and this is actually it's
probably so has 61 with a probability
given by not expand and so on and so
forth when we actually throw away the be
from here we essentially collapse rows
that have the same value for what a
right so one and two and we get the
negation of our clothes we get noticed
one or not why 142 we get not x 1 or not
why to
so what happens now what we need extra
is to negate this locally right and then
we go back to our closest how can we do
that well we take our minus this
particular temporal result and that
would give us our closest and if we now
also throw away a so we project the way
a we get a disjunction of these two
closest which would be our original
closest right right for interest okay so
as I said this is actually a hard
already when T is the only probabilistic
relation and this goes beyond our
understanding of you know of positive
queries where we needed at least two
relations to be to be a probabilistic a
more involved case which for interest of
time I will not go into detail but I
only want to mention the following we
have a new query imagine this query
where s this guy with two variables a
and B is actually on this side of the
difference and r and t are just in a
product you might think that it should
be a very easy query because you don't
have a joint so the only correlation you
can create in there between the
variables in the input formula would
only be because of this difference
because the product just blindly takes
everything from are paired with
everything from T but it turns out that
these the difference is enough to
actually ensure hardness for that in
fact all relations have to be a
probabilistic and and the argument is a
bit more involved but i'll be very happy
to talk with you about this if you if
you like late so how can we deal in
general with the queries well it turns
out that if you look at our STS we look
at possible trees we can construct with
our STS right with the variables a and B
we get very many possible patterns right
we get a pattern like this right where
we join a relational over a with a
relation over B and then we join it with
a be a relation over both a B or we can
have a and B with a difference this is
meant as a as a pattern in the sense
that obviously here maybe an entire sub
query the other side will be an entire
sub query as well right there are very
many patterns well some of them are
reducible to the other patterns be
cause for instance joints are
commutative and associative so we don't
need to consider you know for instance
this pattern and that pattern if we
showed reduction for this pattern then
the other pattern will follow trivially
but nevertheless in case of of the
difference the situation gets a bit
hairier right and as i showed you before
there are different reasons for why
hardness can be achieved is not the one
single reason right and it may differ in
the number of relations that have to be
probabilistic and so on 48 reductions as
i mentioned some of them fall back to
the other so it is very easy argument is
varies you just say you know
holistically that well this is treated
the same as the other but it is true
that there are still a handful of them
left which actually have to be treated
differently it may be possible that a
more general argument can be made for a
larger class of these patterns but then
will not be able to distinguish very
precisely on how many relations are
probabilistic or not and we wanted to
look into that and astonishingly also
you know all these queries are probable
are hard they are hard under the
assumption that in general the relations
are probabilistic if you start looking
into it and then realizing that way in
my query if this relation is
deterministic for instant and suddenly
the query becomes easy right so it turns
out that very very few cases out of the
old possible pieces we have here would
really be hard in the sense that you
know if at least one one relation is
probabilistic than the query becomes
hard are you saying we have a a
refinement of the dichotomy where you
can also tell for which probabilistic
relations you get the hardest yeah I
think I think it can be done i don't
have it written down but i reflected
about this and yes i think it is
possible based on the unknown results
you know I I didn't injure yeah what
comes out of the reduction yeah so um
and then how we basically get the
queries come up with that reduction is a
negative
like you have to yeah matching positive
result essentially adding adding more
more tractable cases or no no no optical
chubby through this classification oh
you're right you are definitely right
about that so what we had to come up
with would be the an Algerine that
actually probably does it in polynomial
time for cases where we say ok if this
relations would be deterministic and
only that probabilistic then we can do
it you are right about that yes thank
you so what happens well unsurprisingly
if we have a pattern and we have our
query let's say the way we actually look
at we look at the matching we try to see
whether we can actually find a matching
from from the nodes in the pattern to
the node in the query such that you know
a would be mapped to a relation that has
a variable a B would be matched of a
relation variable B and a be with
something with a be right for any pair
of a and b's like we can come up with
and if such a matching exists then then
we can say that we can actually show for
that query that that is hard essentially
what happens is that the grounding of
this pattern right in the lineage of it
would be the lineage of that query right
so all other relations are filled in it
in a way that would not disturb this the
grounding of the pattern good what about
the easy queries so for these e queries
the way we do it here which which
somehow the message let me put it this
way the message is a bit as follows
right dan showed you before therefore
some queries if you really want to get
tractability you have to go beyond the
propositional formula methods rise of
the ones that actually work on the
grounding right it turns out that afore
the tractability results we have here
this propositional methods are enough
right it just means that the language is
so that you know it doesn't need to go
beyond that ok so what do we do then we
we take the grounding of the query and
and essentially we show that that we can
compile it into an obd d which
an order binary decision diagram in
polynomial time and then once we have
this weekend we can easily get the
probability of this right and then that
then using what also dan mentioned
before namely that the probability of of
this grounding is the same as the
probability of the query we then get
essentially the probability of our query
anyway we actually solve the problem so
yes five minutes yes so what are the
difference from existing tractability
results so if we now look at no
repeating conjunctive queries for
instance that is we take away the
negation and that's everything we take
away then we showed previously that the
grounding formulas are at once what does
it mean it means that we can essentially
know in a lifted way follow the
structure of the query of the joint
query and produce a factorize the
presentation of this grounding formula
right which is read once yeah and now if
it is read once not exactly means bit
once imagine a propositional formula
where every variable of course once ok
cannot occur several times so then is
very easy to compute its probability and
in fact it admits abilities that have
linear sizing the number of variables
but in case of our language with
negation the grounding of formulas the
ground in formulas are not read once and
I will show an example for that and they
nevertheless admit abilities of size
linear in the database size but they are
exponentially in the query sighs and
this exponent actually can grow with the
number of intertwining sort of
existential quantifiers and and and
negation operators so the idea is is as
follows we we start from hierarchical
queries and then it was we essentially
transform them into more flexible
relational calculus existential
relational calculus where we have a
disjunction of the junction free such
existential relational calculus queries
and then we show that each of them each
of this term is in fact hierarchical in
a much stricter syntactic sense
essentially it simply means the
following it means that if we have an
existential quantifier on a sub-query
then this X which is quantified here
must occur in our relation symbols there
so because of that to get these
independence what what then showed
before that is for every distinct value
of weeks right we have an independent
sub problem then we we need a certain
property called consistency of our
quantifiers namely that all our Terms
can must have the same order the same
nesting order of the of the quantifiers
so you say exist eggs is B must be also
exists exists be in the other case right
if you have existing exists be in one
case and then exist BN x is saying the
other in the other case then then it
will not work why so because if we have
such compatible orders of the
quantifiers then for every single guy
here we can get an OB DD and your BD
this for each of them will be then we'll
have compatible variable orders over our
random variables so then we can smash
them together very efficiently and and
and when smashing them together the obdd
we construct would still have a depth
which is linear in the size of the
database but the width will increase
exponentially with the with the with the
query size you also need to have the
same quantifiers do they have to be the
same were there end of the same time it
is tension or universal so in my case
they are all existing shal because I'm
only doing the the translation so that I
i end up with an existential quantifier
thing so i don't push negation past
existential quantifiers so i will give
you a very quick example imagine d this
query right r times t minus u times V
and then we project away both a and B
and this are our relations which
essentially say I have one to want you
in every single relation one to the
tuples so I do I take the product of our
NT right product of U and V and when I
take the difference what i get i get all
possibilities but where I say R 1 T 1
from the from the first combination of
warranty and not u 1 V 1 or or not you
one v 2 and so on and so forth right if
you look at this grounding at this
formula propositional formula then
regardless how you try to massage it you
cannot get it
once in fact if you look at the graph of
the 49th recipe for the path of length 4
which is a proof that in fact it cannot
be read once so so what can we do we do
the following we take the query we
rewrite it the way we rewrite it is we
essentially we essentially break this
difference of a product into difference
of of components of this product right
and we generate a disjunction and then
as you can see now we can we can
separate out those parts that talk about
be from those that talk about a right so
we can do them very efficiently and the
order of the quantifiers would be exist
exist be in both cases right so i will
get the grounding for the q1 which will
be this one which is a read once because
this one here is read once and read once
is this one so i will get those red ones
here so now if we construct the
abilities will be just a linear size
obdd for sy11 force I to they have
compatible orders because the order of
the quantifiers was compatible right and
then I can I can put them together very
efficiently great so I will just finish
with this slide okay to say only to give
a picture a general picture of what's
going on with this hardness results so
there are some known that the hot on is
in this space they were started by by by
by Dan right with non-repeating
conjunctive queries then with union of
conjunctive queries we looked also at
cases with quantify queries such as
division queries or set comparability
setting comparability when when we
actually the queries look at arbitrary
arbitral east side sets from the data
and compare them and we also look at the
ranking queries ranking means
essentially you would like to look at
the results and only rank them by by
their probability right to say this is
the first this is the second this is the
third it turns out that this problem is
easier than the problem of exact
computation why because in order to rank
it may be that a important sub problem
will be shared by all these tuples right
be the exact probability of every tuple
it may be that you have to solve a hard
problem but if that hard problem occurs
everywhere you can uniformly ignore it
okay so that's so that's the way we can
do that so in general it turns out that
the hierarchal property is not enough if
we want to add Union and in this
junction to our language right and there
are there are there are cases for that I
will not mention now for 40 for the
interest of time any case of for
relational algebra we cannot hope for
anything simply because if you if you
have a union of two equivalent queries
but one is hard and one is easy we
cannot decide right the the equivalence
of them so we cannot say in general that
you know our overall query is is
destructible and that's a and that
essentially means that we cannot come up
with a syntactic procedure to decide
that I still believe that in general the
queries have this separation of easy and
hard okay thank you have a philosophical
comment the classification into data
complexity and expression complexity was
not meant to say that one can ignore the
size of the collector the contoured says
the side of the Queen play a critical
role not giving people permission to
ignore a very important part of to
evaluate we mentioned earlier Moshe toba
I did not give you
lunch ektu yes so so so the the
complexity we have here is essentially
in all size of the data base times the
parameter 2 to the power of something
which depends only on only on the query
in a sense right so okay dddd this can
be in fact large it is true but I think
I think it would be useful in did you
look into which cases are in fact not so
hard and I can give you one for instance
if if all existential quantifiers and by
formula outside are at the outermost
level and I allow you know negation
inside as much as I like then it is only
2 to the power of the size of the
original query and this is perhaps
doable if I have a lot of alternations
then this approach will obviously you
know blow up into the size of this is
that you do a compiler decide how to do
it must take the things into account yes
I don't care it's the complexity not to
worry it's only it's only two to the
thousand not a problem yes no no you are
you are definitely right I'm actually
more of a resistance person than you
know a person who would be discard this
right yeah but but I have to say that I
mean you know it will be it is rather
hard to write a query which actually
would have to to the thousand i would
say right you have to be very careful
how you intertwined the the existential
quantifier with negation to get to that
and i think that this can be can be
computed in fact so you know what is the
exponent there and you can decide based
based on that exponent if you go ahead
with this particular solution yes all
right well if there are no other
questions you can oh yeah the very last
comment you said there should be a
general economy yeah is there relational
algebra query but look that people try
to work on it and it's not known whether
it's easy
I have one but yeah please go ahead we
have a board this one by one s just one
c1 x1 y1 or not as x 2 x 1 or s or not
as x1 by temple so if you think of the
very basis being placed here x 1 x 1 x 1
x 2 then you get a positive as for these
two edges and we don't know what the
complexity of c squared is very key
because he was commiserating with me try
to buy the effects of this credit as
well now we know that this is Cobra can
be computed important event I'm over
symmetric databases in a very
complicated way we don't know what the
complexities on over general device on
this great note so thank you let's take
a break for coffee we reconvene at 10
past the hour 1110 please